with a big england game this should be
one of the busiest days of the year for
pubs
but coveted restrictions are expected to
reduce the number of pints sold by
five million according to the british
beer and pub association
at the willoughby arms in kingston upon
thames the landlord says the final step
in lifting lockdown
can't come soon enough um everyone's
gotta be seated
throughout i don't know what we served
at the table
so we've got capacity for 160 people to
sit
which means we've got government how
many people come in the door
subsequently we've done all ticket in
advance for all the england games
but all those people that are sitting
down also got to be served
so it's almost tripled my staff false
for a game like today
but the british medical association
warns some covered measures should stay
it wants masks to be worn on public
transport and in shops
and it says there should be legal
standards for ventilation
whilst the link with hospitalization has
been weakened it's not been broken
and that some measures should continue
but what it should not be doing is
giving people the impression
that we will have a pre-coveted society
by that stage we would be the only
nation that i'm aware of in europe
that will be taking that stance at a
time when our infection rate is about 10
times higher than that in france or
italy for example
with a little over two weeks until
freedom day cases are surging
up 74 percent in a week lifting the last
of the restrictions will accelerate the
viruses spread still
further but it's better to relax the
rules now says this virologist
at some point whenever we finally lift
all the restrictions off we are going to
see a
a surge and it and and i think the the
reason
why um i i'm arguing the way i am is
because
i think it's better to have that surge
in the summer
than it will be in the winter when we've
got other pressures on their health
service and we
may well have increased numbers of cases
of influenza
with the increased mortality that would
bring on the covid
with almost two-thirds of adults now
jabbed protection of the most vulnerable
is high
and the rollout is progressing rapidly
through young people
who are more likely to spread the virus
we are enjoying a vaccine dividend
one dose halves the chances of the virus
spreading
two doses reduce the risk of hospital
admission by more than
90 percent they are so effective the
government is considering
scrapping the need to quarantine but
double jab people
if they come in contact with someone
who's infected
the prime minister has said extra
measures may still be needed beyond july
the 19th
it's likely people will be encouraged
but not legally bound
to take precautions in confined spaces
thomas more sky news